this week on ford the president of the
philadelphia 76ers the man who traded
for james hardin twice
uh and is responsible for getting jeremy
lin away from the knicks this week on
board daryl mori
[Music]
[Music]
what's up andrew i'm wearing this math
on your owner bro
i love it i know
cause you know that was my nba bubble
hat
i know i was so freaking grateful so we
were just talking about the game last
night and how insane it was did you
catch it i you know the sixers might
have been playing so you might not have
caught it
well not only the sixers playing i'm in
bologna italy
so
we're testing the limits of technology
today
um i was at a uh a game i have to watch
for the nba draft coming up so i didn't
miss it
well so that's one of the things we're
going to ask you about brother is like
how the hell are you are like do you do
your jobs at nba gm i mean like you know
like what are the things you pay
attention to but first we're going to
talk about the game that you didn't see
because there's some people here who
freaking saw this thing and it was total
madness did you hear about what madness
it was
uh i sort of heard it directly
the lead changed a billion times
it was the craziest college basketball
game i think i can remember and it was
so
freighted and like the the new orleans
superdome was like jam-packed you could
just see like the thousands upon
thousands of people they all had either
duke or unc colors on like the whole
thing was like
like this gathering together of these
massive tribes and i have friends who
were dukies and they felt obligated to
get to new orleans because it's coach
k's last game the rest of it like
i i'm enjoying it i like duke deserves
it
so let's talk about that and now we can
bring in some people here who are
actually we're having some thoughts
about this very same thing
um so i didn't know what to like so so
kate was just describing as a kentucky
fan she didn't know who to root for
uh
yeah i think the one thing i found
interesting is
both duke and north carolina fans
neither of them wanted this game they
thought that their lives would be ruined
if they lost so they
the the the downside was much bigger
than the upside for every fan i spoke to
oh i i think that that the players i
think the big the duke players it felt
like the weight affected them a little
bit
i don't know if anyone else watching
that game felt that like
like it felt like the crush of history
they didn't and unc felt much freer
uh
it was such a fascinating game you know
there were moments when
it's it seemed to me like duke was more
talented and like the talent was going
to take over
but then
that often happens but in a one game
one game is one game like from a
scouting perspective these games
actually are not very different from
the regular season game so you learn a
little bit but
you often learn misleading things so i
i don't want to talk too much i think we
got no no let's open up with that
because i think everyone here would love
to freaking hear this
um so so you are tasked with making
uh multi-million dollar decisions up the
wazoo uh and the most attention gets
paid to college basketball during the
tournament um so if you're evaluating
prospects which you are do you guys have
your own draft pick this year
yeah well it's it's up in the air but
it's likely we'll have it yeah yeah so
uh how much do you wait turn um the uh
performance in the tournament versus
everything else
so
the the tournament games
like they're they're valued a little bit
more does that make sense so we
we look at games against tougher
competition uh as slightly more
important
but we don't necessarily treat
uh a a strong opponent in the tournament
very differently from
a strong opponent
during the regular season uh it turns
out there's two types of errors that we
can make in our business there's
you know an error of selecting someone
and they turn out poorly but there's
also the error of someone you could have
selected that you did not select
uh and
tuning across both those errors
uh you can you can both overweight uh
and underweight the tournament so you we
do a lot of tuning to sort of put a book
properly weighted and it turns out
treating it pretty close to a
game against a regular season game
against a strong opponent is about right
so this will be a lot of fun because i
feel like the odds of you drafting uh
one of the top prospects are very very
low you're not going to end up drafting
uh paulo by cairo
i'll just just just so you know because
you don't know the nba rules i can't
actually talk about any of the players
uh that's one of our we have lots of
rules um
but uh but i can talk about the teams um
and yeah i would like you know we got
tyrese maxi out of kentucky speaking of
kentucky uh at 21. there was 21 o'clock
21
a couple years ago and he's turning out
to be looks like that you know all-star
so don't don't don't don't assume we
can't get someone in the 20s
well i was just saying because one of
the things i was noticing as like an nba
fan uh
is that people didn't know who the
number one pick was going to be coming
into the tournament um most of the stuff
i i saw said chet holmgren was like the
you know most popular consensus number
one pick um but that seems to have
flipped and it seems to have flipped
based on the tournament and then there
was part of me that was like why would
you change your opinion based upon these
games
um and so that was one of the the
reasons why i think everyone's wondering
it's like you know is that is that
normal
that's an excellent question and goes
straight to the heart of my job actually
so i love it
yeah so what we do is we do like these
process checkpoints not to i'm sure
there's a bunch of philadelphia
folks on here
whenever whenever a uh hey matt whenever
a uh prospect
moves dramatically
up or down on your draft board and
generally around this time teams have
sort of a loom skirt
you actually try to start to put your
guffler together a little later it turns
out the earlier you start to rank and
evaluate
in a formal way the more that those
early rankings will get sticky
and give it more weight than they should
in the final eval so we try to push our
rankings
out to later
because of that
and but once you do set it and someone
moves maybe maybe they were in the draft
last year and they pulled out and
they're in the draft again this year now
they're in a very different position
they're much higher or much lower
we uh one of our process checkpoints is
why are they higher
is there actually new information what
is it and is that information something
that should have moved them that much
and to your point yeah if someone's
moving a lot based on the tournament
that's almost for sure wrong
uh it's it's
definitely been the case that people
have overreacted
to that information more than
underreacted to it
yeah that that does make sense
and these times it's more important than
ever that we save money wherever we can
particularly if you're running a small
business and one great way to do this is
stamps.com you can get exclusive
discounts and rates that will save your
business money we're talking about 30
off us postal service rates and up to 86
off ups do not find yourself stuck in
line at the post office ever again
stamps.com is like a post office on your
computer you can save money save time
and focus on the things that actually
matter to you whether it's in your
business or in your personal life so
start mailing and shipping with
stamps.com today
keep more money in your pocket where it
belongs sign up with promo code yang and
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code yang stamps.com the post
office of the future
[Music]
so this game last night wow
but part of it was that as an nba fan i
knew that duke had like three or four
first round future first round draft
picks
on their roster and then unc i think
consensus going in had approximately
zero
i went to do i went to a new game in
broadway this year
and i thought maybe
maybe you're talking like seven or eight
not all coming into this draft
but over
like
players currently on the roster
it's it's very deep and potential under
the players i thought yeah so the so
there that was the the talent
differential you kind of sensed where
periodically one of the duke players
would make a play where you're like whoa
just like
turned around and dunked it or you know
like did something
um really athletic
uh and
so the natural thing that happened to me
watching last night's game is i started
rooting for unc
um because i think you naturally just
start rooting for the less talented team
that's kind of
scrappier playing freer
uh and it was interesting
well i'll make a comment on that so that
there's this uh
very persistent bias
in wagering wagering should be efficient
and we're not allowed to really draw
anything
nba but we are allowed to wager on say
brackets and things like that um and
there's a very known thing across
gambling in all places
forest racing is worth most talked about
where people like betting the long shots
the underdogs
in such a way that those bets are
consistently inefficient which shouldn't
happen
so i'll give you an example that i have
friends who do a lot of this they have a
fund
where they just bet the favorites
consistently bet the favorites
and and vegas and these these
the lines makers know that this is true
they don't mind
losing a little bit on the favorites
because they get so much action
on the long shots and they set the line
you don't get paid
you don't get paid enough
uh if that makes sense for these long
shots the the long shots this year right
they to win the tournament you could bet
that before the tournament
the odds of them
of saint peter making it that far we're
so low that you should be paid way more
than what their payouts are wow this is
so interesting uh
because
uh i definitely have been subject to
that particular bias and i like to think
of myself as very bias free
um but when i have screwed around with
uh gambling like i tend to bet the
underdogs because i'm like ooh like that
person that's a dog like you know their
chances are better than that
people hate betting favorites because
for example here's where it often comes
from say college football
you know you're you're betting what's
called the money line which is i think
texas will be rice
this weekend and you bet a hundred
dollars and you might make two dollars
that turns out to be often a very good
bet but people don't love it it's just
not exciting
we call it in the business sort of
picking up
picking up quarters ahead of a bulldozer
so you're gathering quarters out of the
bulldozer but if you ever trip or
whatever if there's ever like a random
upset you know then you lose all your
winnings for like
50 60 70 bets that said it's still an
official bet
the favorites moneyline especially are
almost always an efficient bet um
in vegas
wow i think you might have just either
saved or made me a lot of money daryl
well it's more fun about the underdog so
yeah if you wanna you
i have sacrificed enjoyment in the
service of my wallet
which i should probably embrace because
i have kids uh you know they're a bit
younger than yours so like i still have
to
you know minor minor matter old now
i'm i'm old
well i i'm you know obviously met your
your daughter who's uh
incredibly
smart and uh you know on her way so i
mean you should be very pleased and
proud
um
but yeah so i ended up rooting for unc
even though i have all these dooky
friends sorry dookie friends out there
including uh someone who's very near and
dear to to uh forward or zach grauman my
campaign manager who i literally think
flew into new orleans uh to watch that
crushing loss but you but you just i
just found myself rooting for the
scrappy underdogs and that they were
less talented but they were playing
freer and like you could kind of sense
the moment getting to the duke players
and so as a result
it was kind of like you know wanted
wanted unc to prevail i don't know if
anyone like so uh you know daryl was not
doing his job overseas but like i don't
know if any like matt or kate did you
have the same sense when you were
watching that thing
so i
got a little
emotional about coach k uh he's been my
rival since i was a little girl as a
kentuckian and so then i was like oh i'm
going to miss coach k so then i was like
well then do they deserve it and i was
like no and then so i was very back and
forth and now
i don't know about the championship
because i really don't like ku so
i i might be for unc for this game you
know so one of the things that happens
to me too is that so i don't watch that
many college basketball games um but if
you watch a team you become familiar
with the players and then now you like
very much kind of root for the folks
you're familiar with so now having
watched that game i i like now like this
unc squad
i'm like
go
that's one of the main positives of
college basketball on the draft for the
nba is that the players come in with
with some name recognition
uh which
is which is hugely valuable for the nba
um
you know
high schoolers you know i know them a
lot of the people tuning in may know
them but they don't yeah people don't
know that name unless they did go to the
ncaa tournament and things like that and
and kate i think you'll learn to hate
coach john shire as well so i think
he'll be fine
with your uh with your you can have your
hatred
so
let's talk about that because that's
highly interesting there was a point in
the not so distant past when i think
there was a bias against international
draft prospects
and then there was a minute where that
over corrected the other direction
[Laughter]
and uh yeah that's the name that pops to
mind maybe partners
you you live bargaining so because
you're a knicks fan right am i right i
did live barnyani uh you know that so
um so there's a period when i just went
the other direction everyone was looking
for like the next
um
who was it the next uh you know
yeah
for sure
um i can talk about retired players so
you've noticed i'm using names so yeah
playing anymore
but yeah no it absolutely overcorrected
i mean obviously the uh the foundational
players were
you know sabonis was father um
holy [ __ ] arvida is a bonus
man by the tim by the time that guy came
over he'd already lost his uh you know
jumping ability and he was still but he
was still amazing right so that's that
yeah that's a
that's a great great memory and uh
yeah it was basically lithuanian players
like they called them russian players
but they were really with the landing
player so it you know probably the
russian team in 92 to face the dream
team i believe was
all lithuanian players except maybe one
or two
i'm pretty sure all the starters will
we're looking
oh this is a trivia question let's see
how you do andrew there are two
countries in the world
where basketball is the number one
sport that's watched
uh i gave away one lithuania is one of
the places where basketball is number
one there's one other
country in the world that have
basketball number one it's a very hard
answer so i might just have to give it
too quickly
if uh i'm going to guess another one of
the like small eastern european things
i'm just going to guess like croatia or
serbia one of those two
that's what i would go with it turns out
soccer real football is bigger there the
philippines is the other country
actually wow i should have known that as
a proud asian oh you know there was
actually a dude
who was like
um running this like filipino basketball
league who was like pitching me on this
that's a real thing actually quite a few
nba players end up in the philippine
league either either they're not good
enough for you know the euro league one
of the main european teams or it's
someone who's
you know 34
still me still wanting to play and make
money
uh luis scola didn't play in the
philippines but he told me he's a very
smart guy he had from argentina he was
on the great argentinian team he said
i'm going to play basketball until
someone tells me i can't make money
anymore so if it's going to be in
argentina if he went to china he went to
italy he's now running a team in italy
where i am
so uh so to the point uh do you think
now it's uh it's
balanced uh accurately if someone's
international versus college because it
was like underweighted for sure there
were inefficiencies and then it was like
everyone was going after the next dirk
and you drafted some some dudes too high
yeah yeah for sure the joke was if you
added a an itch to anyone's name in
college they would go up five to ten
spots
or wait i just want to throw the other
guy in there yeeji and the end like the
famous like workouts against the chair
and as a and as an asian guy like i was
really rooting for ye
he he turned into a very good player in
the cbo the chinese that believe
um
but obviously no one in the united
states saw that um i think yeah the
expectations
for him for example so
your question's a great one it was way
underrepresented like
teams should have been desperate to go
get you know um oscar schmidt or like
these famous uh you know players uh they
then
uh they've been over corrected i
actually think at this point they're now
back to slightly undervalued
yeah i think
there's been quite a few failures and i
think you know teams are slightly uh
slightly undervalued there's some very
very
you know obvious counter examples that
you can talk about all mvp candidates
and things like that but
the next tier down i think is a little
bit um
is a little bit under at this point
[Music]
so i feel like you're being
very very diligent heading over to
europe to watch
someone play
um
i feel like as a gm
uh you know you obviously have to
allocate your time in the way you think
it's going to be most
effective uh so what goes into
some observing someone play live that
you can't see on tape
uh and uh in this case you probably had
scouts check out whoever the heck the
prospects are is it the kind of thing
where it's like look i've had scouts see
some prospects like four or five times
but you just need to see and feel the
player live
yeah so the answer is different for my
role as the president or a scout
so
there's two things that i that's such a
good question though that's the first
question that that i think people should
ask
um
so
i like to see them live once there are
some things you you can pick up
they're very hard to know how to value
though and honestly they can be very
misleading so
i like what you said earlier where you
were like i feel like i'm pretty
unbiased
generally that only comes from someone
who literally tries to train their brain
to not be biased like you know you're
still going to be biased but you read
both the new york times and the
economist or the wall street journal you
you
intentionally follow people on twitter
who you think are born abhorrent people
because you want to understand their
perspective
right like you have to intentionally
do that i just want to throw interject
something i took a test that is out
there and i i don't know what it's
called now but it's called red brain
blue brain
and it was designed to measure partisan
bias
uh and they told me that i had a very
rare zero
so i was very very proud i was like wow
like you know like like genuinely
independent but uh continue that's
pretty cool i actually want to take that
to see see how it turned out and and i'm
assuming that's not measuring like your
policy views and things like that i
think that's what measuring is like how
to how skewed is the information to be
processed dude i i don't know how i mean
they they tested this [ __ ] it was like
out of harvard um and i have to see what
they're doing with it we actually tried
to connect them to van jones because
like they wanted to popularize it which
i was all for
um but i'll give you an example like one
uh question on it was like what is the
family name in uh who stars in duck
dynasty
uh and i did not know
i have to admit i don't remember i think
i watched it a couple times when it was
big yeah but but uh apparently that's uh
or
like who directed the movie uh get out
uh what was one of these
you know jordan peele
yeah so apparently if you knew that then
like you're much more likely to be a
democrat um
whereas if you need a duck dynasty thing
you're much more likely to be a
republican so it was so it was like it
was interesting where i was like oh [ __ ]
like that that [ __ ] works was my
response um but they were like well you
know we've tested this thing like five
ways to sunday and like yeah it works
well that's actually a funny thing from
my prior career i'm doing a lot of
forecasting and things like that i'm
always amazed like if you give someone a
survey instrument of 10 to 30 questions
and then you just literally read the
answers back to them they'll go like oh
my god how did you how did you know like
all these things i'm like yeah you just
literally told us
like apparently you can also i know with
the automated things that create
problems on social media in terms of
people you know getting pushed you know
more and more extreme content and things
like that
they can they can like take you in like
i don't know like five web links
somewhere like the sites you got
apparently these things were just a few
stupid survey questions and they can
really freaking hold on that's it yeah
yeah we do we think we're so complex
it's tough man we all get to get
segmented into you know 32 categories or
whatever well to me like we used to say
it in consulting with you know basically
like we we would go and read the read
the client's watch and then say it back
to them look your watch says 5 30 and
they go oh my god like how did you know
it was 5 30. that's such a good study
so yeah people should be skeptical of uh
these instruments sometimes would not be
quite as amazing honestly
so you were talking about the biases
that come with uh seeing someone in
person
oh yeah yeah so um well i have a couple
things so
i feel like
if it's someone who we might select
i like to see them in person and talk to
them i would say that actually there's
this overwhelming evidence that the
interviews and talking to them
are actually probably skew your decision
making more that more than helps it
but i go into it feeling like i'm going
to weight it very low because i know the
predictive power of interviews and
things like that generally if you're
doing an interview you're mostly testing
for a person's ability to interview
not their ability to play basketball or
ability to be a campaign manager for you
or
anything like it's it's a it's a it's
it's own skill
being good at interviewing and it
doesn't predict a lot of it it doesn't
predict much else
that said i i don't want to actually
select the player turn to the owner of
the 76ers and he'll be like well what is
he like of the person i'll be like
search me man i just saw some tape
i i we're giving him six to seven
million dollars but i've never you know
i have no idea
um i actually think our offers might be
okay with that so i like that i also
like you do pick up things that pre-game
habits like there was a situation at the
game tonight in bologna uh again you
don't know how to weight these things
when you pick things up q's
uh one of the players hit the ball out
of bounds in a scrum and the ref it was
one of the weirdest situations i've seen
the referee
called it out on him and he actually hit
it out but it was a very hard call to
make
he
the player went out of his way to go to
the ref and be like hey ref
that was a great call you got it exactly
right i hit it out and the ref had no
interest he kept ignoring him the ref
kept like trying to get him to go away
and this guy's like trying to be a nice
guy
and the ref's like stop talking to me
but it was like interesting that he felt
it was real i mean i think he's trying
to influence obviously
but i i just found it fascinating that
he was insistent on making sure the
revenue that he thought it was a good
call
[Laughter]
that is you know certainly you know
there's no other way to get that except
to be there and apparently when we pick
someone this year we're gonna be like he
picked him because he was friendly with
the raps he's a sportsman you like to
like you pick that story out
yeah exactly
so i don't know if you're allowed to
talk about this but uh the nba playoffs
are approaching i'm actually going to
tell you a story and you don't have to
comment whatever i'm like friendly with
uh an nba player um he's on one of like
the teams that's going to be in the
play-in uh that
10.
um and he said the one team we don't
want to see is the philadelphia 76ers so
i i guess you can hear that and like it
uh he was just like we're just trying to
not play the sixers
[Laughter]
well um yeah you have to it's hard to
manipulate it until the last day
so i do like what the league's doing
this year there and they did it last two
they're they're doing what the premier
league does they're gonna start all the
games at the same time so it's harder
for teams to
easily
know exactly what they what outcome they
want
there is some very limited internet
movement around saying like the number
one siege should be able to choose their
opponent have you seen or heard anything
about that would you be for it yeah the
g league did that i would be for it
um i actually was against it um
initially and i'm usually for everything
honestly i love
i love new rules because usually if if
someone's proposing it it's probably got
a lot behind it because people hate
change
uh i was sort of against it because i
like the variance so all it does so the
nba already has the most
the most sure advancement so the one
seed beats the eight team at the highest
rate of any sport the two beats the
seven
so i liked that there were these random
things like brooklyn i could talk about
teams where brooklyn obviously yeah
brooklyn has to be the scariest [ __ ]
eight seat in the history of the world
you know like it's
extremely scary last year the lakers
were thought of as you know pretty scary
as well
um because they were injured and things
like that or you know if denver were to
get all their players back or you know
where there's some scary lower team yeah
seminars yeah the clippers get all their
players back so you know i i have no
insight into i have no idea if these
players are coming back
but that would be those are the kinds of
things that keep you up at night because
you play 82 games you're like oh we
positioned ourselves well
and now here comes you know brooklyn who
you know maybe is the quality of a one
seed
yeah so you before what so what what
changed your mind in terms of being
against it and now you're
a good team foreign
self-interest like most things in life
if we actually got the top seed i'd like
to be able to select uh i'd like to be
able to select and avoid you know having
to play a brookman for example well you
know it's true i mean you guys could
still wind up with the number one seed
so it makes sense you'd be we could yeah
yeah and uh you know frankly to win the
title you got to beat everybody when we
were in houston facing golden state
we pretty much had modeled it out it was
like a 94 chance we were gonna face
golden state at some point and our goal
was really just to win the title so we
were like does it really matter if it's
the first round or the third round the
reality is it does matter for your fans
like it's fun to advance and get farther
but in terms of your title odds at least
at that time when there was a dominant
team like golden state there isn't now
then you know you're going to face them
then it's not it's not as big of a deal
to face them in the first round sticker
on the third round oh incidentally i
texted with our mutual friend jeremy lin
and he says hello oh great you know i
love jeremy yeah yeah
he would have been huge the injury
really
sort of hurt you know affected his
career unfortunately yeah apparently the
feeling is mutual he's he still uh loves
you too daryl um and i i i can tell my
own jeremy so i don't know people know
this but like i'm a huge jeremy lin fans
you can imagine being an asian guy who
plays basketball and seeing like my
dream play out in real life where he
became a point guard for the new york
knicks
and then when they uh
actually you were a part of this what's
going on
but he left new york for houston or the
contract you gave him
uh and the knicks didn't match i then
divorced the knicks i was like i can't
deal with this [ __ ] like these guys like
this is the team that play that paid
jerome james 30 million and paid eddie
curry 56 million it's like they can't
pay jeremy lid like you know whatever
the heck the rockets are paying him
um you know there's a lot to that story
i'll let you say it but there's a lot to
well i mean i'm sure jeremy told you all
that was going on behind the scenes
there so i mean we just you know i
actually haven't talked to jeremy about
it because i thought it would be kind of
like you know uh like a potentially like
awkward or painful subject uh like i
just know this stuff from like the
um from carmelo's communication and like
dolan stuff but like as a long time
knicks fan what jeremy lin was like the
ray of sunshine um for us to lose him
over money just like was just by
breaking point and the knicks had
problems you know in terms of management
and whatnot anyway so i said screw it i
am breaking up with the knicks
one of the best decisions i've ever made
i'm sorry knicks fans who are on this
thing but uh and i get it because if you
didn't have like as strong an attachment
to jeremy as i did then you'd be like
well you know like hate to lose him but
you know life goes on um but i was like
a hardcore knicks fan and then broke up
with him i spent a year as like a
vagabond i actually bought some rockets
paraphernalia you'll be happy to know so
i was like screw it i'll like follow
jeremy to team then you know you guys
got james harden so jeremy had a
secondary role but then a little while
later the brooklyn nets
um signed jeremy uh as like their
centerpiece essentially during this
rebuilding phase
and so i was like yeah i guess i'm a
nets fan now so like i brought my kids
to see
jeremy play
um and you know he got injured very
badly like pretty quick um
and so that you know and then his career
really hasn't um
bounced back um but it's pretty wild man
i mean you were like directly for like
my entire you're directly caused by a
tire
the reason we went for jeremy just
obviously saw his talent is we were at
the time it was
to your point pre james harden we were
chasing variants as we call it anywhere
so
you really only win in the nba when
you're
um with top players top five 10 15
players in the league those are the ones
that drive
your ability to win the title you need
the good role players too but you know
all the good role players in the world
won't add up to a title
and so we were chasing you know jeremy
you know for a time before he got hurt
had a very non-zero chance to be an nba
all-star level player i know a lot of
people would disagree with that but
that's
very hindsight by us like you know i
think we had our the odds of jeremy uh
being an all-star in the five to ten
percent range and that's actually really
good like people are like oh it's only
five to ten percent that's really high
if you think about it that's you're one
of the 24 best players out of 450 in the
league that's a really and the 450 in
the league are already an extraordinary
exclusive group and you're in the top 24
is insanely
high achievement so to have even five
percent odds is something
almost nobody has any chance to even
talk about you mean i don't have a five
percent chance of being nba all-star
daryl i'm hurting
yeah say though i will say something
that not a lot of people know that you
you were in the nba draft at one point
andrew we had a chance to draft you
um just based on the nba rules were even
kate was in the nba draft everyone
everyone who turns
22 and the calendar year is in the india
draft and eligible to be drafted uh
anywhere in the world so it's it's only
someone who's younger than playing two
has to declare for the draft you know
generally though
there's no surprises although a little
side story this is not my idea i believe
this was kevin pritchard the the gm of
indiana who came up with this
his idea was you know late second-round
picks have a really extraordinarily low
hit rate you know we've had some good
success and you can name the genomies of
the world but
so his idea was to
basically sell it you know draft the
most interesting man in the world and
sell the pick oh yeah it's a good idea
i don't know if it's a good idea but
it's a nice it's an idea i thought
people would find it yeah it is funny i
mean you could cash out at a higher
level because you're
second-round draft picks for like you
know 800 thousand a million three
million or whatever it is you could sell
it for like 10 million and you're a
genius it is capped now you can only
sell it for like i think the cap now
it's six point six million or something
like that only six point six million
andrew
see there there you go
[Music]
um i'm friends with a guy named dan
porter who started a company called
overtime and now they have their
overtime elite then there's also the
g-league ignite um so there are these
like new leagues that are popping up
that are essentially alternatives to
college
um in theory i feel like they would be
better at preparing kids for the pros
because now this is not a knock or
whatever but like a lot of these kids in
my mind are like kind of pretending to
go to college
so
it feels like they would take away the
pretense and they would get professional
level training maybe more nba relevant
coaching
you know the the flip side of that is
that you know if they don't end up
making the pros then like it could be
they don't have um as strong a set of
options um but it seems like would make
scouting a breeze because you don't have
to go you don't hop a plane to europe
you can just go to atlanta and like
watch multiple players
uh do you have a read on how you compare
uh these new efforts and leagues to yeah
i would say there's there's three paths
and i think
you know the commissioner silver has
talked about this but um you know
they're overtime elite is an emerging
one i think the nba is involved with
that one
the g-league
has been a direct um
you know path as well
and then
the one of the real emerging paths is
through australia so a lot of a lot of
players are choosing australia because
they can you know they they'll pay a
decent amount they speak english you
know australia is a nice country
all those kinds of things so australia
has become
a pretty competitive path with vnc as
well
you know i think everyone should just
choose whatever i i like that there's
more paths for people and they can make
the less choice for themselves
um i know there's some
you know people who sort of wax poetic
about
uh when everyone stayed three or four
years in college but i i do think you
know i i i'm i'm big on choice
whether it be i know that's why you
that's what you're here
right
voting or any other innovations
uh so before we open it up to questions
you're actually someone who's been pro
third party or some kind of political
dynamism for
quite some time do you want to talk
about what brought you here today really
grateful that you're here to talk to
some forward party donors and supporters
but yeah like to describe like how you
wound up in sort of a third-party camp
well i'd say i think ranked choice
voting was one big thing that brought me
to your platform along with you know i
think
um
you know i i have to admit initially and
i had heard the idea
of uvi before uh so it's sort of one
that you have to like
consider and think about before you go
okay makes a lot of sense so
um but in terms i'm big on
people being able to choose being uh
self-actualized
um and
you know i think that's where you get
you get the the most performance of when
someone is
able to and not everyone can do this
obviously but they're able to choose
something
close to you know their work matches
you know the challenge of the work is
both not too hard or too easy and also
in a vocation that that you're excited
about i think um
you know things like ubi would allow
people to get closer to that uh and then
in terms of ranked choice voting to me
that's of math like it just makes sense
like yeah
we want after like rank choice voting
and there are different voting
mechanisms we do a lot of voting in our
draft process actually
um you want the most people at the end
of voting to feel the best about the
candidate that was selected
and you know a two-party system without
rank choice voting doesn't you know
gives you like it's almost like if you
were to say let's design the worst
system yeah possible it's the worst yeah
so
so you know that that you know again i
i didn't know prior to your presidential
run i had some friends who are friends
of yours
um in your previous uh you know venture
uh for america is that them yes yeah um
they knew you we didn't know each other
but when you when i saw your candidate i
asked my friends they were like oh yeah
that's a guy you want to really pay
attention to so that's when i started
paying attention and then you were the
only one actually trying to say anything
intelligent on the stage so that that
appealed to me so i get a lot of trouble
in politics i'm really more about the
people so i you know i like mitt romney
i just i've always liked him as a person
i got in a lot of trouble earlier in my
career when i was saying i like mitt
romney i just think he's a good human
being that i would be fine with leading
something he's great he strikes me as a
moral human
yeah and i think that i felt vindicated
when he's
taken some you know positions that have
been hard for him that were the right
positions in my mind and i think you
know you're you know again we don't know
each other super well but i saw you as a
high quality person i could feel like i
think i could get behind that person
uh so i look more at that than policy
frankly i suppose if there's a policy
that would be that's completely
abhorrent i probably wouldn't support
the candidate but generally people are
in some policy range that's not uh
not completely crazy or you wouldn't
even make it through the filtering
process to be on a stage somewhere
you know one of the things i've been
struggling with daryl uh is that at this
point
your policies uh your policy stance is
more of a tribal marker than anything
else at this point you know what i mean
and then people use it to be like oh
uh you can't be for this person because
therefore this or that and like we're at
a point in american life where it's
pretty much irrelevant what each of us
is for
because because the system is not going
to produce much of anything like you
know
okay can i tell a story on that and this
was where i the sadness of politics i
won't say the politician but i knew one
of the candidates running for a very
prominent office and i knew his campaign
manager very well
through my consulting years and
when he was putting together his policy
statement
one of his policy statement was a very
anti-immigration stance he was running
as a republican and i was like
well he's not anti-immigration he's
pro-immigration what are you talking
about it's insane to be
i'm just giving my personal beliefs now
it's insane to be anti-immigration in
the united states like it's the
foundation of our country it's one of
the reasons why we're one of the best
countries in the world and so dynamic
so to be anti-immigration to me is
actually insane like one of the craziest
things that's happened in the united
states it makes me the most sad so again
this was a candidate i knew directly i'm
like
they're not anti-immigration he's like
yeah he has to say that or he will not
get
in the republican primary sure you know
yeah i know people are running
i know people are running as republicans
right now who are saying [ __ ] i know
they ha they do not think or believe at
all
yeah which is awful right that the
process is forcing that now i understand
there are a lot of things that we have
to go through that sometimes
we make compromises to achieve a higher
goal
but like that's a really sad one like
that you you're forced to the anthem
immigration to
to get to a higher office and to me it's
crazy
it's a symptom of the dementia of the
two-party system honestly daryl because
you know there's like a clutch of people
they just happen to be highly
overrepresented in the republican
primary
[Laughter]
yeah well one thing i'm like super
super free speech right as you know and
sort of famously
and and you know defending my friends
in
hong kong but that
neither party seems to be a perfect
speech it's like actually terrifying
like well
because
each side now uh
is rewarded for having this kind of
ideological
back and forth um so if you if you say
like hey live and let live then that
actually weakens your hand
in terms of like the two-party dynamic
that is going to you know drive us
um insane and to civil war and the rest
of it in in in my uh estimation
yeah i saw you tweeting about the the
civil war book and
i have not read it i just you know read
the summary like every other person on
earth does now and it was it was pretty
uh the bullet points were like i'm like
okay
i see
i see where some of these things can be
pretty works i don't know what def con
we're on but
you know according to her we're in like
defcon three of five um yeah which is
still much worse than most americans the
nice thing about being a deathcount
three is you don't remember if five is
bad or one is bad yeah you're right in
the middle it's good
it's true
[Music]
um well thank you daryl we're going to
turn to some questions but first we are
going to announce a winner of the
forward party swag for being here today
and his name is michael osso michael
thank you very much hey kate do we have
anything do you want to say anything two
or four michael i know michael's here
today oh there you are michael look at
that yeah michael's on michael i'll be
emailing you uh the free how to get the
free merch but uh congratulations
thank you michael asa
yeah i actually met michael when i was
on tour um great young man um super
exciting
and um and now yeah and as it was in
houston yeah it was in houston fantastic
michael
and now let's take some questions i i've
seen some in the chat uh people have
been entering them diligently they're
probably for daryl and not me which is
delightful
[Laughter]
it doesn't doesn't happen often i'm
guessing yeah
they're they're used to me daryl they
didn't hang out
everyone saw with me i saw you had so
many people tune in which was pretty
exciting yeah i i i assumed that we were
gonna
be you and i talking to to the the ferns
in the background of your your spot
there but it looks like you had a huge
turnout which is awesome yeah yeah no
it's good fun um i mean [ __ ] i mean i
learned a lot from this again you saved
me a ton of money i just have to [ __ ]
start learning to bet favorites which is
like
it's just boring you just
that's a good lesson for you if you want
to make money you have to like be boy
you have to be vanguard you have to just
take a little small bit
over a long period
that's like
very good advice we sense it and the
house always wins et cetera et cetera so
so matter kate i'll let you moderate go
ahead and shout out a question sounds
good and i'm going to try and uh switch
back and forth a little bit between
basketball and politics here and uh
we've got a few that kind of bridge the
gap between the two of them um and i
will direct some of the more
controversial ones daryl towards andrew
in case you were not able to uh weigh in
on them for i'm i'm look i'm not a
politician but i'm very good if i can't
answer i'll just say i can't answer it
jacob asked we're going to start off
with a fun basketball one picking from
all retired players can we get your
all-time starting five
huh
oh retired players
um
yes uh good one
well i guess you gotta have gotta have
kareem on there
uh so that's an easy one
um
i think you have to have larry bird
i think you have to have michael jordan
so we got three
yeah
um
i think it's harder i think
i have tim duncan and kevin garnett in
mind but i'm probably biased by like uh
a recency thing
well what i'd say andrew and i get a lot
of a lot of trouble when i say this but
you know kevin
garnett is probably almost certainly
better than female gold
um
i know
like now i'm gonna that's gonna be the
clip when i get aggregated and hated on
after a thing um but the reality is like
the players are getting better and
better and better and it's like you can
measure it and probably just look at
shooting percentages on
common areas of the floor and things
like that the players are getting more
skill
kevin was i think arguably the you know
he's at least in the discussion for the
greatest defensive player of all time
um
and
you know the biggest you know obviously
the 2008
team the doc rivers coach to the title
in boston
uh to me kevin garnett was the biggest
driver of that in his defensive problems
so i'm struggling after mj tim duncan
kevin garnett i could try uh i could cop
out and just be like jordan and bird but
like i don't know if i believe that [ __ ]
so i'm thinking
well the other thing is what's
interesting is so kevin mchale isn't
obviously our coach in houston amazing
coach knitting guy
uh
even always tell me how bad larry was on
defense so
so it's it's hard to be bad on defense
of being one of the all-time greats but
here's a here's a trivia question for
you andrew you again i'm asking you hard
ones so larry bird is his last year at
indiana state
uh how many rebounds per game did he
average
i mean [ __ ] it's college he's uh you
know like six eight six nine so i'm
going to say like
10. it was 14
which is like insanity because it's a
slower you know so there's fewer
possessions all these things so
like anyway the only reason i said it
was like larry bird was absolutely
insane yeah
yeah so i'm stuck at three i don't have
to work on the other two we can come
back to this one matt
i think it's got another interesting
aspect too oh [ __ ] maybe i throw dipping
in there pippin was a beast yeah
but i i think we've we've seen this on
olympic tv you also have to consider the
ability to play together as well as just
the the innate skill sorry
like tim duncan and kevin garnett are
kind of my versatile big men and then
pippin could be like the kind of spider
man in the middle and they're like that
was the ball handling i need one guy
who's like a
sweet shooter
maybe i'm gonna this is a little bit of
an overrate but i'm not gonna throw ray
allen in there just to you know
vomit
i was laughing you reminded me of the
dog and up when you when you're like
wait a minute pippin squirrel you know
there's all these great players yeah we
only get to pick five though so far i i
feel like if i could talk about the
current players it would be a lot easier
like i we have reams of data on who the
best players are over the last 25 years
but the the players before that are very
very hard to judge i just kareem has had
an insane efficiency number for so long
it's pretty hard both
and strong defensive mode
look at that he's plucked kareem out of
like the you know 70s 80s he's only the
the leading scorer all time you know
um so it's hard to find him
[Laughter]
oh have you watched an episode of this
freaking laker show on hbo uh this uh
i have not i mean actually adam mckay
who i love
he did don't look up that did the show i
think he's producing it but yeah i'm
sure he's helping
and um and i haven't watched it i i i do
need to i do i know everyone in the nba
is really angry about the show they're
all very angry so
uh i it's got adam mckay's fingerprints
all over it um i i think you'd enjoy it
i'm enjoying the heck out of it
yeah i mean i've i've heard the person
who really hates it with jerry west but
it makes gary west not seeming like uh
you know like a goon much more so than
you know he's ever seen in terms of
public persona so who the hell knows
if there's a if there's a documentary or
something about the the bulls or the
lakers if you're named jerry you're
going to get crushed jerry krause or
jerry west you've got a on this
um but yeah watch it it's fun
adam mckay
um it's interesting he's uh you know i
haven't sat down with him at all but
like there are a bunch of people
around that i that i think are like
political independence and are are very
interested and interesting
he's uh he's probably a one issue guys
whereas i know him pretty well so he's
he's he's he's climate change which is
important it probably wouldn't be if i
had to pick one issue wouldn't be my one
issue but it is for him and for good
reasons i think he's that's why he made
the whole movie obviously
it was oh that's why that's why like
magic johnson and kareem are just
talking about recycling all the time
this show and i'm kidding
[Laughter]
they invent bottled water or something
oh yeah don't look up great movie
climate change obviously you know may be
the most pressing existential issue um
you know one of the cases we're making
is that no matter what issue you care
about if you don't get political reform
we're not going to solve it you know
what i mean i use it like this
[Music]
the great point and i think i connected
with mike zarin in boston but he was
trying to push rank choice voting did i
i can't remember they didn't win in
boston they in massachusetts
i don't think it did win um it was on
the ballot it would have won if a couple
of key officials hadn't come out and
shat on it down the stretch
um so so that's you know it's like
existing officials will rarely be for a
system that uh brings genuine
competition
right yeah i don't want to stop this
gerrymandering thing that's helping me
get elected for 43 years yeah probably
yeah i mean [ __ ] it's gone from 83
non-competitive districts to 90
non-competitive
like that like the parties just don't
like competition at all well this this
brings up a point
math can be used for good or evil right
so
so gerrymandering is like
taking really smart mathematicians and
really figuring out how to create
entrenched power you can you know to me
like people hate facebook and there's a
lot of good reasons to hate facebook but
like to me
like technology is just a tool it can be
used really horribly right or it can be
used for sharing you know baby photos
that you know with people you don't see
so like
it to me like people point too much like
the same with crypto like crypto they no
one seems to be in the middle on it and
i'm like yeah it's gonna be a useful
tech for what solutions it solves people
can use it really horribly and
hack and do all these things or they can
use it really well like why i don't
understand people can't seem to be in
the middle this is like like people
can't seem to have a
an average opinion on anything yeah like
a nuanced textured uh opinion because
we're in the land of polarization it's
either good or yet
the best thing ever the worst thing ever
et cetera and one of the things you have
to avoid is something like crypto for
example getting politicized because as
soon as he gets politicized and one side
loves the other side hates it then you
know it'll fall prey to the system i
think it's one of the ones that they're
like confused they're like i can't
figure out what my tribe is telling me
whether i should hate it or not i think
they both like free speech they both
settled on hating
crypto as my sense but you know well i'm
actually working hard right now and
trying to keep uh crypto from getting
squelched by dc started something called
lobby three
talking to various uh regulators and
other folks um trying to keep it from
getting turned into a football
well my crypto wallet thanks to yeah
don't thank me yet but it's going to be
an interesting six months sort of that
way and it really is going to be six
months like this it's coming down the
pike so buried in the biden executive
order was language saying he wants the
legislation done in 210 days which now
is about six months from now
and that's timed because they think
they're going to lose control of the the
house or maybe like you know both the
house and the senate in november so
they're like hey let's get these rules
out before we're out of power so
it really is kind of a legit scramble
right so sorry i keep i'm not more
people asking questions we haven't taken
it off no not at all it's good fun so
we'll leave the sixers playing the
sixers playing nine minutes so i do have
to do it oh no we'll let you go in eight
it'll be good yeah um
thank you for doing this from a farmer
hey matt you got another couple of
questions before uh the top of the hour
yeah this is uh this is a little bit
related to what you all were just
talking about uh and i know it's uh it's
topical for you andrew and daryl you
spent some time in a good chunk of time
in texas and it's specifically about
will hurd he had an article in the
atlantic andrew who was just on your
show i know you've spoken with him a
little bit and he's talking about
attracting the center or left and center
right for a silent majority and kind of
we were just talking about how
everybody's so polarized so uh how do
you make that happen and especially you
know will's talking about doing this
down in texas which is seen you know as
a republican stronghold but there's a
lot of blue energy there how do you how
do you build this uh this bridge between
these center groups to really get people
elected you know this is the trillion
dollar question i'll take this because i
talked to will about it um i talked to
other moderate republicans too who are
trying to do the same thing will's doing
except they have to if they go through a
primary then they end up being four [ __ ]
they're not four
to daryl's point
um so
will's shot at is to try and energize a
larger uh slice of the population to
vote in the primary uh like that that's
his goal
um it's a tall order because there's a
certain segment of the population that's
conditioned to vote in the primary and
everyone else just ignores it um it
could work if you wound up with like a
slew of new voters
in in that i mean what we're doing with
forward is trying to make the case like
look the primary system itself is broken
like i applaud folks like will who are
gonna try and go in and
uh enlarge the voting base so that it's
less crazy um but i'm i'm dubious
because you know i think the process is
stacked against them um so you know so
that that so this is the my answer to
the person who's looking at this like i
talked to moderate republicans and some
of the moderate republicans are
leery of running in a primary for this
reason because they know it's not going
to be like a a genuine conversation
you're seeing some reasonable
republicans retire for this reason too
it's very tough
but if you don't know who will hurt is
he's this former cia operative daryl do
you know will
i don't know him though
um you'll get to know him because he's
going to be one of the these up and
comers who's going to fight for the soul
of uh you know certainly a republican
party um but you'd like him because
check him out computer science major
from texas a m
uh cia operative for nine years in
afghanistan uh pakistan and india runs
for congress and wins serves three terms
and he's the most one of the most
bipartisan republicans only black
republican in the house for a while um
uh and then he retires and then now he's
back to try and like fix it um and so
he's being mentioned as a potential
republican contender um in 24 uh or some
other race
well i feel terrible because clearly all
computer science majors who work with
the cia are great people because i also
qualify both those accounts look at this
i i'm telling you will heard is going to
be your jam um so anyone who's
interested in uh i gotta go i'm going on
will hurd's uh zoom in a minute here
sorry sorry andrew
i've moved on to a new candidate
i go for it i mean [ __ ] so so one of the
things that's happening too is like i'm
trying to help folks like will um but
like you know we're all like
you know kind of aligned and tied
together a little bit um anyway so we'll
we'll like but i my interview with will
is out tomorrow um if anyone is into it
matt one last question for me and daryl
before daryl goes and does his job
this one this one is a little bit of a
hot button issue here but uh
people want to know if you think that
kevin durant calling out eric adams new
york city's mayor about the vaccine
mandates and kyrie being able to come to
the arena as a fan but not a player had
an effect on the uh the mandate decision
in there and what are your thoughts on
uh in either case what are your thoughts
on that well i can't talk about kevin
durant but uh i i will say i'll just
talk my uh andrew um
actually no you you didn't meet my wife
oh no you met my wife you came up right
yeah i know you met my daughter my wife
said yes that's right yeah that's right
yeah sorry anyway she called it she's
she's one of the last baseball fans on
earth uh is my wife she she's
religiously a mets fan because she's
from new jersey or that part of new
jersey
and uh you know as soon as this was like
i'm telling you like seven eight weeks
ago she was like as soon as the yankees
and the mets can't play that's when
they'll change it because no one no one
cares about the net
so that was she she completely nailed it
so
my sense is that that was it
the
lots of powerful people from the yankees
and mets organization were able to move
uh the political levers to get that to
change that's nice i i think i would
agree one of the open questions to me is
like i thought to myself man how many
baseball players aren't vaccinated
apparently a [ __ ] ton of them
well that's one so i've had to deal with
it it's it's interesting
um
like a pretty high percentage of nba
players especially at the beginning and
even part of the way through were not
were
not vaccinated
um
i can't really tell you why that is i
ended up having lots of one-on-one
conversations explaining
you know why i thought it was a good
thing part of the reason and and i've
talked about this online quite a bit
there were a lot of noble lies told by
by people in power that i think really
hurt vaccines you know things like hey
masks don't do anything at the beginning
because they were trying to save them
for
like
these kinds of things where they have
some larger purpose but their their
people know their [ __ ] hurt your
ability to actually get people to move
later and i think it's i think it's a
real problem so when i spoke with the
players one-on-one for example once you
explain relative risk
and like because i had a player who had
not had killed it and had did not want
the vaccine and i was like
you have the easiest decision if you've
not had equivalent and not had the
vaccine
you're going to get one or the other
you're just going through this
so it's really picking which one you
want
and you know generally you're probably
going to want the vaccine some people
might want to just get it i mean
especially if you're 25 and healthy like
our players are
so anyway so that you know that
eventually he was convinced to do it um
the hard ones i had another player who
had gotten covered and was also being
told to get the vaccine
again
i would get the vaccine that was that
was the choice we've made
but that's a less easy decision that's
not as straightforward
people want to make it straightforward
so he he appreciated i was like actually
giving him the trade-offs versus like
you know take vaccine you bad person you
know like you know which is basically
the narrative right so oh yeah
yeah i know i it sounds like you
communicated uh with him honestly and as
a human being uh
and that probably helped a lot um and
that's that's a fantastic lesson for us
all uh something i learned too it's like
it's what you're saying but then it's
like how you treat someone how you're
communicating and the latter is
sometimes more important than the former
it's like i've said [ __ ] to someone a
big look i totally disagree with you but
like blah blah blah blah blah and
they're like all right it's cool
have you saw this andrew like i'm sure
you think about all these things really
deeply now this is my question i'm
jumping the question right now please
like to your point when you when i can
get one-on-one and talk politics or
issues or different policies with people
it usually goes fine
you can have in their back and forth you
can hear them out they can feel like
they're very understood
and you can have a real conversation
that obviously doesn't work if you're
running for president like you did or
even mayor or like whatever role you're
going for
has anyone solved like the ability to
have like a communication mechanism that
works in mass it doesn't like kind of
send to people or treat them like
they're idiots like you're like
i yeah for better for the worst darryl
the closest solution i've seen for this
is long-form conversations on podcasts
um and and then you're not directly
communicating with someone but you're
communicating with someone else that
maybe they know and trust and then like
they get some of the same vibe
um in person is probably the next best
because like you can talk to a number of
people if you get out there
um
and
i found that that's the single biggest
way to move someone is that if they meet
you in person then it's almost
impossible for them to believe [ __ ]
about you later because they're like
wait i met that guy and like you right
did not seem like he's like you know
like
me or like for this crazy thing or
whatever the hell it is
yeah it just it just doesn't scale but
also i i feel that in my job
people like stereotype because i like
math and i was a computer science major
like that i'm terrible with people and
generally like when i meet someone
they're like no he's actually like a
nice guy i can hang out with
but i could i bet if you hold
you know there's not many people even
know who i am but of the people who
would know who i am if you pulled them
if they heard my name it's got to be in
the low 90 percent would say oh he
probably is terrible around people
even though i personally would say
that's not true
well i think everyone here can vouch for
the fact that daryl is not terrible with
people he's actually a very good
congenial sort uh and you know you're
from the midwest uh you know
you've constantly ohio mostly ohio
mostly ohio he's got that kind of like
sensible midwestern vibe i dare say i
was born in wisconsin so it's very
wisconsin yeah well the the
non-polarized wisconsin
yes
daryl mori thank you so much
i'm going to say just for the purposes
of this conversation go sixers have a
great time tonight
thank you cleveland so you can say it
it's not against your meds